look
in any fps nothing feels better than a
crispy one tap you can practice your
lineups or your spray control
all you want but nothing is cooler than
just doming someone with a single click
of your finger and we're not gonna
discriminate here we looked at
everyone from the pros to the solo queue
superstars
these are the top 10 valorent one taps
starting off at number 10 is team
solomid subrosa with an absolutely
filthy pistol play he's going to spot
all of them right now
one two three four four five when tsm
faced off against immortals in the clg
blitz cup
fans watched with wide eyes as sub rosa
snuck into a position
where he was completely hidden from his
enemies
it is composed of drone wardell hayes
cutler and sabrosa
with the trap set sabrosa peeked out to
find he had immortals
right where he wanted them this is gonna
be huge he's gonna spot all of them
right now
one two looking for the ace right now
and it's about to be peaked out here
silva arrow to come out and he's gonna
win this fight and he's done
with another headshot that is what seven
bullets use
it doesn't get more satisfying than that
and that's how you start this off oh my
god
shroud is certainly no stranger to one
taps and if we're being honest
they don't get much sweeter than our
number nine entry
with his back up against the wall in a
1v3 situation
shroud had nothing but a vandal six
bullets and a dream
and sometimes that's all you need
my gosh
you can't do that that's not allowed
one bullet to spare boys he may not have
the same
name recognition as the first two
entrants on our list
but youtube user blueberry takes our
number eight spot with some
nasty peeking
blueberry titled this clip four bullets
five kills
no misses and to be honest i don't have
anything to add
it's just clean as
[Music]
we're going galactic now for our number
seven with a superstar play
from milky way oh that's a bad one
dignitas looked dominant against g fuel
krabby patties in their first game on
split
during the ignition series and this play
shows you why they took the first map
without dropping a
single round look at this oh that's a
bad one
for the win you don't have to be a
galaxy brain to see why
milky way's play is out of this world
we've got aproto showing us why he's the
sheriff god
at number six
it was a 1v5 and all aproto had by his
side was a
sheriff with six bullets loaded for a
proto
that was one bullet more than he needed
to pull off the ace
[Music]
[Music]
we have a jumping one tap over a sage
wall that we
still can't believe happened
now a sage wall is supposed to offer
protection
you're supposed to feel safe behind it
but how can you
ever feel safe when there's a
possibility of a blind jump one tap like
this
i just jump to him
coming at number four we have a clip
from metal user zild that you honestly
have to see to believe
[Music]
apart from his reaction the best part of
this clip is that he actually
predicted he would pull this off i peek
a
mid
one tap only watch let's see it okay
i'm gonna wait to get your sheriff
moving on to number three we have
wardell making it
look easy
[Music]
now wardell may be known for his op play
but he's no
slouch on the vandal either and if you
can pull off these kind of taps
you get to demand your teammate chant
your name it's just how it goes
[Music]
[Music]
what's my name what's my name what's my
name what's my name baby
say
[Music]
coming in at number two we have youtube
user kayla pay with a clip that would
make
some pro players blush
[Music]
sometimes you have to line up your
weapon to get the kill
other times the enemy just lines up for
you when it happened to caleb
he didn't drop the ball
[Music]
[Music]
would be complete without a heco
highlight which is why the 100 thieves
captain's ability to stay
incredibly cool under pressure makes the
top spot on our list
just down to hiko he's been soaking with
these shotguns can he be so once more
tries to take the long peak when he gets
tagged heavily doesn't even matter
he'd go 1v1 in a 1v2
situation during a 100 thieves versus
nrg
game at valor and challengers heco had
to choose between
rolling over or going super saiyan with
the one taps
i'll let you guess what he chose tag
will be there but you able to find the
kill just down to hiko
he's been so good with these shotguns
can he be so once more tries to take the
long peak but he gets tagged up heavily
doesn't even matter he go 1v1 bang
bang he go for two
all right guys i hope you enjoyed that
i'm gonna tap out from the one taps for
now but just before i go
i want to know from you which valorem
top 10 list
do you want to see next do you want one
that only includes clips from pros
we are all ears just let me know in the
comments section
subscribe if you haven't done so already
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next one
you guys both got hit by my old i said i
was gonna old hookah what do you guys do
you
can stand there's a guy you stand to the
right
not the wide outside of hookah
you open us yeah what dude what do you
mean
what do you think i'm gonna do i'm gonna
know who can you go to the right you
don't stand where i'm gonna oh
guys guys don't get hit by this
are you kidding me